you refer to a lot of these kkk klansmen
as your friend are they really your
friends
or are they more acquaintances you get
along with both
in the beginning there was one plan and
chapters of that clan
spread all over the place today there is
no such thing as
the ku klux klan because of all the
infighting
well i realized that right after mark
was assassinated i just didn't know why
why do people hate you when they don't
know you you had worked with chuck berry
for
30 plus years i put in all this hits
with him what are your thoughts on
jackie wilson oh man one of the greatest
singers of all time
and for some reason he's not as famous
as elvis
as chuck berry there's a reason for that
tell me why the reason is racist
there were no black idols on tv why are
black people so angry towards you i'm
sitting down
talking with the enemy i'm talking with
the oppressors if you want to be heard
then you have to hear the other people
too so i allow them
that's how you're able to sit down with
these racist
kkk members and listen to them the grand
dragon roger kelly
you two became so close he named you the
godfather of his daughter
yeah he did racism you're not born with
it
[Music]
our guest today is an american blues and
rock and roll
musician author and activist perhaps he
is best known for his work to improve
race relations in america by speaking
with klansmen
to spark a new mindset that eventually
enables them to leave the kkk and start
a new life i'm honored to introduce to
our audience
daryl davis mr davis welcome to
valuetainment
thank you very much it's a pleasure to
be here i'm excited uh
beyond words for uh to be speaking with
you today so what i wanted to do
thank you what i wanted to do is sort of
uh start the conversation and frame the
conversation
with what i interpret as sort of your
overarching
theme um and really agenda
when you do what you do and what i would
take from that is this that the overall
theme is
how can you hate me without even knowing
me
is that fair to say absolutely how can
you hate me if you don't even
know me to be exact uh to use the exact
quote
um explain that how that mindset really
entered your life
well it started when i was felted by
rocks and bottles and pop cans during a
parade
in which i was 10 years old and i was
the only black child
participating in this parade while the
vast majority
of the audience you know lining up the
sidewalks and streets and stuff
uh were white i didn't have any problems
and i never had any problems in my life
up until that point
we reached one point in the parade and
all of a sudden i was getting hit
and i was marching with the cub scouts
now because i
i didn't have prior experience in this
my first
thought was though those people over
here on the sidewalk
don't like the scouts you know so
i didn't realize i was the only one
being targeted until
my scout leaders you know ran over and
covered me with their bodies
and escorted me out of the danger i kept
asking them why why are they hitting me
i didn't do anything
and all they would do is just kind of
shush me and push me along
telling me everything would be okay so
i had no clue until i got home and my
parents who were not present
during the parade you know were asking
me how did i fall down and get all
scraped up
i tripped or something and i told them
what had happened
and they sat me down and explained to me
why this happened
and that was the first time i'd even
ever heard
the word racism i had no clue what they
were talking about
now that's because my background my
parents were us
foreign service so we spent a lot of
time overseas
and i grew up as an american embassy
brat
so i attended international schools uh
this is back in the early 60s
and my classes over there uh
were full of kids from all over the
world because anybody had an embassy in
that country
all of their kids went to the same
school so you know i look here's a
little kid from czechoslovakia
a kid from japan the kids from russia
from france germany switzerland
nigeria wherever all different shapes
and sizes
all different shapes and sizes and
shades of color
and that was my norm
[Music]
that's all i knew you know now while
people may have had funny accents
or they didn't all speak english and i
certainly didn't speak
you know czechoslovakian or japanese or
whatever we all
got along we all worked together we
played together we had slumber parties
you know that was my norm
and it wouldn't be until i would come
home
that my norm changed and here's what's
uh
what's uh interesting about it adam i
remember as a kid
you know we had tv and this is uh
it was black and white tv and then you
know a few years later
it was color tv and that was a whole
different world
you know just like opened up uh sort of
like i just going today from you know
uh one-dimensional two-dimensional to
the three-dimensional or something
color tv was it but when i
would come home from the an overseas
assignment of my parents
come back home it was like going from
from technicolor
to black and white it was reversed
because i would come home i would be in
either all black schools
or black and white schools depending
upon whether i was still in the uh still
segregated
or the newly integrated school and the
newly integrated school was just black
years of white kids
there was not the vast diversity
of colors and shades that i had overseas
because diversity had not really come to
this country at that point and let me
ask you something daryl this was what
mid 60s in the boston area where was
this exactly
yeah yeah okay it was um well you know i
would you know i would come
every two years so uh no matter where i
was in virginia and bc
in boston but the boston thing you're
talking about
uh belmont right outside of boston was
okay and at that point i was one of two
black children in the entire school
i was age 10 and i was in fourth grade
it was a little black girl of second
grade
so consequently uh all of my friends
were white
and uh it was those um male friends who
invited me to join the cub steps let me
ask you uh mr davis can i
can i call you daryl are we coming daryl
or
dd or we talked about uh triple d uh he
idiot double d yeah
daryl what's your middle name again
dwight daryl dwight davis triple d
i love it amazing double d triple d so
let's take it back before we kind of go
deeper on this let's take you back to
being 10 years old it's 1968
and they had to have the talk with you
right yes um
you're 10 years old would you explain
what
the talk was and what that talk still
is today that black parents have to have
with their kids what is the talk okay
well at that particular age uh it was
that you know you are capable of being
anything
you want to be you know don't let
anybody tell you that you can't be
anything that you want to be you work
hard you be honest
you know you have you have patience you
have discipline uh you can you can
achieve
anything and uh but at the same time
be aware that you know that there are
people
who simply you know do not like you
because of the color of your skin now
the
the problem with that was the fact that
i didn't believe my parents and what do
you mean you didn't believe them just
because you had never experienced racism
so you thought they were lying what did
you think it was exactly
yeah yeah i believe they were lying i
didn't know why
uh because you know they never lied
before so why are they lying now
and so you remember thinking that at age
10 like my parents have never lied
before
but all of a sudden they're lying to me
after this cub scout incident
because i was an only child so i didn't
have you know a lot of my friends had
brothers and sisters younger older
and you know uh whose experiences were
passed down
you know to to the younger siblings and
so i didn't have that
so whenever i had an issue a problem a
question
uh the only people i could go to were my
parents and my parents
always uh either solved the uh
the question or or problem for me or
gave me the tools of which i could do it
and they it always worked it was always
truthful it was always it always made
sense
but this time when they were explaining
what the problem was to me because i
couldn't figure it out
uh or i had the wrong answers i just
thought people just you know
uh i didn't know why they didn't like me
i thought maybe because i'm the new kid
on the block or something
because i've only been there a couple
months so when they were explaining to
me this time
i didn't have reason to believe them
because the people who were doing this
to me
looked exactly like my friends my
friends
right there in school in belmont or my
friends from the american embassy
overseas
or my little german friends my finnish
friends my
sweetest friend my australian friends
so and they had the same color of skin
so and i was the same color you know
associated with them as i was
on the streets of belmont massachusetts
i didn't understand the problem
because i had not grown up here i
already had good experiences
with people who looked like the people
who were um
perpetrating this uh this violence upon
me so why would i think
that was colored my skin so it sounds
like it sounds like this talk that your
parents had with you was very uplifting
meaning
you could be anything you want to be
daryl you can do anything you want to do
anything is possible i asked you
initially
about this talk what do you think that
talk sounds like today
that parents have with their kids is it
the same thing is it different
is it more regarding police is it still
about racism is it uplifting
what's that talk like today it is uh
well it depends upon the parents of
course too because there are some
affairs to tell
you their kids you know you'll never
amount to anything or whatever
but uh the talk is always based upon
race
and and the the degree to which is based
upon race
varies as a child gets older because for
example
uh that same time you know i went back
overseas you know after that school year
and i was back to what i call normalcy i
was around everybody we all got along et
cetera
but every time i would come home there
would be some racist
incident that involved me uh the talk
uh continued but it was revisited at the
age of 16
when i began driving and i was told by
my parents you know look you know
there's a possibility you know you'll be
pulled over by the police
uh and i understood now you know that
people do judge you by the color of your
skin
uh by age 16 i you know i realize you
know this is a real thing
well i realized that right after martin
luther king i was assassinated i just
didn't know why
why do people hate you when they don't
know you but i realize it does go on
so by the age of 16 i'm being told by my
parents you know that
the police may pull you over and even if
you're not doing anything wrong
be polite be respectful keep your hands
on the wheel
do exactly as they tell you even if they
give you a ticket and you know you were
not doing whatever it is you know they
told you you were doing
just take the ticket sign it we'll take
care of it we'll go to court we'll you
know
do whatever unless you know you were
speeding or you were running a red light
or whatever
um so you know i had that and
and were you ever pulled over oh many
times
really i still am i still am and my
father was uh
was pulled over quite quite a number of
times you know we live we were the
second family to
second black family to move into our
neighborhood
uh when i was around that age and uh it
was a brand new neighborhood right
outside of
dc because you know my father had you
know worked at the state department
i worked for the state department and uh
you know he drove a mercedes and
the cops would pull him over in our own
neighborhood thinking
that uh he walked in and drove out
and and then you know when i began
driving the same thing was happening to
me
you know i must have walked in that
neighborhood and driven somebody's car
out
stole a car were you were you driving
your father's mercedes did you have your
own car at the time no
no he would not let me drive his car oh
not because he thought i was gonna wreck
his car
but because he knew that and that's and
that's another thing you know i
i didn't quite understand uh i believed
him but i
sort of felt you know maybe he wasn't
letting me drive because he didn't want
me driving his mercedes
right but what it was was he he knew uh
you know that a young
black you know black boy age 16 driving
around in mercedes
uh just you know was when i draw the
attention
of the police but the kids in my
neighborhood they had fancy cars
so what were you driving i was driving a
chevrolet impala
all right i'm feeling that yeah but i
still got pulled over
there's something important about that
year 1968 that you're talking about
because that is also the year
that america was just basically burning
down that was the same year that mlk was
shot
that bobby kennedy right so i remember
you told the story this is the
documentary
i think accidental courtesy is the name
right yeah which i've watched
several times you told a story that you
were watching
i believe i dream of jeannie now
actually the other one do it
bewitched how can i get those two wrong
they're two basically uh
you're watching bewitched they both were
beautiful women yes elizabeth montgomery
and barbara eden
facts so you were watching uh bewitched
um and breaking news came on walter
cronkite came on
and basically announced that martin
luther king was assassinated
and you're the one that told your father
the news
correct me if i'm wrong and he broke
down
crying and this was actually the first
time that you saw your father
crying tell me about that moment
i didn't understand it uh first of all i
didn't really know who martin king was
at the time really yeah i you know i
spent
you know a lot of my formative years
overseas and so you know we weren't
having you know
civil rights marches and all that kind
of thing over there
uh so but when um i you know
it happened in the middle of my program
and usually um it was something
significant you know that everybody
could relate to
whenever a newscaster you know burst
into a middle of a program
and since i didn't know who mlk was
i didn't understand you know people you
know die
all the time i didn't understand the
significance of it
as to why this could not wait for the
six o'clock news why did you have to you
know first in my program
why are you messing up my bewitched
favorite program precisely
so but i figured it had to be something
important and maybe i just didn't know
who it was so i wanted to kill my father
maybe he would know and as soon as i
mentioned it
he was in in his little office typing
and as soon as i mentioned that his hand
made his head fell into his hands and he
said oh no no no no
no you know and he was like i'm not
gonna know what's going on here
and he'd be insulting about it and i
just did not understand that
i've never you know i've seen my mom cry
i've never seen my dad cry
um but who is this person that you know
that's making
you know my father cry it's not a
relative
you know and so he began explaining all
the things
that uh mlk had done uh he had also
marched
with uh mlk your father yes yes wow
and um you know i so it was something
going on in your head that you knew
something was way off your father's
crying breaking news
something is different going on even at
age 10 yeah you seem like you were very
innocent at that time
did some things change within you at
that point
uh no not not right then um
i just understood that you know this
this person
was was a very significant person but i
wasn't
feeling it because i did i still didn't
know but
uh that evening things began burning
you know and a lot of violence and
rioting
and um it was just
crazy and and and everything changed and
then i began
feeling it because my world changed
uh as i explained a few minutes ago uh
all of my friends
were white okay and
the next the next day um april 5th
because he was assassinated on the
fourth uh we went to
we lived in boston initially well when
we first returned
my father was was working on on his um
on his master's degree at uh at bu
boston university
so we live nearby and uh
we went you know we went down into
boston and picked up some of my friends
from the first school that i went to the
school was so bad
that we had to move to the suburbs it
was so behind
so we moved to the suburbs for better
schooling that's why we were in belmont
after after you know almost weeks after
i started school
so we went and picked up some friends of
mine my little classmates from boston
and brought them out to belmont to stay
at our home because things were just too
dangerous in boston
buildings were burning down everywhere
people were fighting in the streets
looting and all kinds of craziness
and so i saw that firsthand and
all in the name of this new word that i
had learned a couple months prior
called racism so uh you know my world
was beginning to change
but the real changes occurred because
you know as a 10 year old kid
you know you have lots of friends and
you play and you get together after
school after your homework
you go outside and play with them all
that stuff well guess what
uh all of my friends being white in
belmont
uh some of them were no longer allowed
to play with me
not by by by my parents but by their
parents
and their parents had always been very
nice to me i'd come over
to their home and if they were eating
their parents would invite me in and fix
me whatever their kid was eating
and i was at the table eat with them
then we'd go outside and play same thing
if you were in my house my mom would
give them whatever i was having
you know there was no you know color
issue
and now all of a sudden i'm being told
when i knocked on the door
oh you know little johnny can't come out
you know he's staying
he's singing today you know for no
reason that was right after 1968 you're
saying like right after that
it was the next day the next day wow
okay uh and then half an hour later i
see the guy down at the park
and i'd be like i thought you couldn't
come out uh
no um my mom doesn't want me playing
with somebody the kid straight up told
you that
yeah wow and uh and i i i said why
i i don't know she just doesn't
and the kid didn't even know wow right
he didn't know okay
uh in retrospect i understand it
you know because we lived in a duplex
uh the landlady lived on you know
downstairs and we lived upstairs
and there were two front doors right on
the front of the house birds and arms
are going straight upstairs we had all
that space there uh
now at the age of 10 you know i i
thought of her as an old lady
i don't know how old she was she may
have been 30.
[Laughter]
i just turned 40 darryl you're making me
feel horrible well yeah we gotta figure
you know
at age 10 you'd be ancient right
[Laughter]
so uh you know but you know she was
probably
my parents age maybe a little bit older
uh you know young by today's standards
you know in any
regard but uh but at age 10 yeah anybody
over
over 15 was probably old um anyway
she owned the house and we had a big
porch and sometimes my friends and i
who play on the porch set up little army
soldiers or whatever that we did
there was no line going down the center
of the porch
that designated my side and her side and
she was super nice if she made cookie
she always bring us some
give it to me and my friends on the
porch or whatever well guess what
just the next day or the day after
whatever you know following day
we were playing on the porch and she
came out she said daryl
i'd rather you play on your side of the
porch and then she said
um i'd rather you all not playing on the
porch at all why don't you go inside
this is a white lady this is the white
lady and and
and this was the person that i knew as a
nice white lady
i mean she was always nice to us and now
why is this uh
lady being so mean uh i didn't know
there was a side to the
porch she said i'd rather you play on
your point on your side
i didn't know there was a sigh i mean
the whole time i've been there i've been
playing all over the porch
and now all of a sudden the porch has a
side where's this invisible line that
i'm not seeing
and then she's telling me uh not to play
on the porch
i i need to play inside uh you know
what's going on here
i didn't get it in retrospect of course
i get it now
because racial tension was so
high and you gotta understand that era
this is
in the middle of the civil rights
movement martin luther king's home was
getting bombed you know by the clan
uh all kinds of things were happening um
everybody ever has been assassinated on
and on and um here
this lady is sending me inside my house
who used to be so nice
so in retrospect she was trying to
protect
me and my family as well as her and her
property
because you know we were like in an
all-white neighborhood and suppose you
know somebody driving by
realized oh this white lady is renting
to a black family
uh maybe we should come burn across in
her yard yeah if you remember
was the kkk prevalent in boston at that
time
absolutely yeah so even in the northeast
this isn't just a southern thing you're
saying no no no it's not
it was not um and uh if you remember
viola louisa uh viola louisa was a white
lady
who uh you know participated in in our
civil rights back in the 60s
and she was driving a black uh civil
rights activist
to go to a march and the clan happened
to see her on the highway
as they were driving there to protest
the march or whatever
and while she was driving they put up
alongside her car
and shot her in the face murdered her
right there on the highway
uh the you know the car went you know
she was shot dead while she was driving
and of course the car veered off the
road and crashed
uh the black guy survived he was in the
passenger seat
but she did not and all because
she had a black man she was a white
woman uh
you know driving a black man around uh
now you know
in later years like just back let's say
or three um when i was
uh interviewing this one clan leader um
shortly after i interviewed him he
uh went to prison for he and one of his
clansmen
he pulled up to a stoplight in his town
here in maryland
at the stoplight right in the main
intersection of town
uh there was a vehicle to the right had
a black driver and a white
and a white woman in the passenger seat
and he and the classman
of the classroom got out dragged him out
of the truck and beat him with an inches
of his life
they left him in the street for dead and
he was dead and drove
off in front of 11 witnesses this is in
92 yeah is this right around the time of
the oj trial or is that
pre that that's probably that was 94. 94
right right wow some things haven't
changed now
how would you compare what was going on
then
right i mean mlk uh bobby kennedy
everything you just talked about someone
just pulling up to a
white woman just because she's driving
with the black man shooting them
how would you compare that to today with
the racial tensions today is it even
comparable
or is there some similarities there are
yeah there are many many similarities
you know these these attitudes you know
prevail because people don't want
change people are creatures of habit
that you know human beings are
and and when they see this they [ __ ]
they feel that their
landscape their way of life is being
eroded
uh if you will take uh again you know
this
this is a little bit musically before
your time
uh you take somebody like like elvis
presley
what was it that people did not like
about him it was the white establishment
that did not like him at the time uh the
the black
uh establishment embraced him because
elvis was doing
black music and but then when he hit the
and
but here's what happened white kids they
were tired of hearing their parents
music
they wanted something new that you know
that they could call their own
and they found it in elvis he was
different he was different from white
people
he wasn't different from black people
we've been doing that music all along
right right and elvis had gravitated
towards it
he was singing blues he was dancing
around like a black guy wiggling his
hips and knocking his knees
etc that was totally different for white
people
and my kids loved it white parents hated
it
you know now of course over time that
evolved he became
they gave him the title king of rock and
roll and all that sort of thing
but initially they did not like him at
all because he was a setup he was a race
trader he
you know he was he was doing something
that was not you know
our culture he was despicable he was
corrupting white
youth daryl let's stay right there and
talk a little bit deeper about music
right
so um you know i would i would call
music the great connector you actually
said
that everyone likes music even the kkk
right um you play blues rock and roll
jazz country you've actually said if
you're
paying i'm playing i'm playing i love
that i love that
you know you said um you wanted to be a
diplomat as a kid when you were growing
up you know this is obviously you know
in your in your
adolescent years high school maybe going
into college you said you
you perhaps wanted to be a diplomat an
espionage
agent a computer programmer but then you
saw a rock concert
that featured you'd mentioned elvis and
the legendary
chuck berry the original king of rock
and roll right
that's right so what happened in that
rock concert and what sparked in your
mind
you know the path that you set on in the
music career
i just saw how happy people were
uh it was amazing people who
would never meet uh the person on stage
not even come close but yet that
individual
up there just had total command of 20
people you know all cheering etc
uh they all were happy all colors all
kinds of people
all ages um i thought you know
wow that you know that person is
touching people that he will never meet
i thought you know that's what i want to
do i want to make people happy
and music was a medium to do that
and that particular kind of music
see you know was very energized
uh you know that rock and roll stuff so
i decided i'm gonna be a rock and roll
artist you knew when you're
from your first concert you're like i
gotta do this well i i knew uh from
seeing them on tv
and then i had to go see them in person
you know see you know it's just real
who was at that concert who was playing
at that concert you went to where when
was it
the the first rock and roll concert i
went to was chubby checker
uh lloyd price and some other people and
and i saw the same thing
and now i i you know of course i knew
who elvis and chuck berry were
but um i had not seen them at that point
chubby checker was famous for the twist
absolutely yeah yeah and i learned how
to dance when it came out
you got a little twist in you still you
got a little twisted absolutely
let me see a little twist can i see a
little twist
[Laughter]
love that the sock hop the twist yeah i
love that
i saw elvis first uh march 10th 1973
in roanoke virginia that was my first
elvis concert
1973 elvis yes yep and uh
and then the next month april i saw
chuck berry
now were you playing music at that time
no not only on
on the record player wow so what's the
first instrument that you picked up that
set on this
uh life passion of yours it was a piano
but back then they didn't really have
portable pianos you know so you can go
to a gym or whatever yeah if there was a
piano there already
you know you're out of luck you know now
you have keyboard security under your
arm you know whatever
but uh so what i did was you know elvis
played guitar
chuck berry played guitar so i got a
guitar
and i trans i transferred everything
that i had taught myself
or had been turning the piano by my
friends under the guitar
so to this day i still kind of played
guitar like you were
like you played piano and uh you know
guitar is easy to carry so i was able to
look into my friends homes
or open mic jam session or whatever
let's take the guitar
and that's what that was the first time
you started playing right there and then
yeah but i i just started out with you
know with playing the instrument i
wasn't i wasn't very good
uh so i sang i started out singing and
then you know
so you have this baritone like almost
like a barry white voice going on have
you ever heard that before
oh yeah oh yeah
but uh you know i i didn't always have
that uh i was a tenor back then
mm-hmm yeah i mean i can't hit those
notes now gotcha
but yeah you'd be doing some sweet love
songs like
i if you were in a modern day r b uh
band like if you weren't boys to men you
would be that guy that would be like
hey girl you know you and i you would
deserve so much better that would be you
in today's music well you know i mean
you mentioned uh barry white yeah and
i've heard i have heard that a lot
and that depends upon the age of the
person hearing me yeah uh you know the
older people
and given the style of music you know
that i do uh they would say brooke
benton
hmm i don't know brooke benton i gotta
read up so you gotta check them out i
gotta check them out brooke ben let me
write that down
we're learning things here today write
down a song called lie to me
brooke benton lie
to me all right also check out snap your
fingers
joe henderson joe henderson yes knack
defenders i want our audience to check
this out joe henderson snap your fingers
and brook benton lie to me amazing so
do you have a favorite musician of all
time because you said you had mentioned
you had worked with chuck berry for
30 plus years yes chuck berry johnny be
good
you know what else uh who else or what
else
both what were your favorite songs from
uh from chuck berry what'd you play with
him and
and what other artists i played all this
hits with him um
johnny be good rollover beethoven sweet
little 16 ninja
maybelline carol school days all of them
amazing so much monkey business i mean
so you know johnny b
is my favorite song uh from chuck and
it's my favorite song of all time
uh also like little richard's uh i like
anything he did
but my favorite little richard would be
uh lucille good god i miss molly
i love jailhouse rock by elvis
hard-headed woman
when you saw the scene you've seen i
assume back to the future when michael j
fox did johnny be good you know i was a
kid when that movie came out that
melted me i love that anytime that movie
comes on i mean
do you see that scene that must have
like what did that do to you when uh
michael j fox did that it was a great
scene it was written
and it's it's a scene that everybody
remembers from that movie of course
you know of course let me ask your
thoughts and that's the power
of that chuck berry rock and roll of
course you know it only took up a couple
minutes in the movie
but it it is the most memorable scene of
the movie
and the whole movie was great but that
is the scene that sits out
just like pulp fiction remember that
movie of course
yeah exactly and what and what song were
they uh playing
that was chuck berry uh chuck berry yeah
cllv yes exactly is that chuck berry
music
wow it jumps out at you well you had
once said
that chuck berry perhaps was the
greatest civil rights hero
in america i want to say the greatest
but was a civil rights hero
because because of him white white
people or
black people white kids black kids had
danced together
for the first time in american history
is that right
because of the music he created yes and
the other artists played it as well
but but they would not be playing it had
it not been created yet of course
uh elvis you know elvis presley jerry
lee
lewis bill haley in the comments carl
perkins buddy holly
all these people uh as well as little
richard bo diddley fast domino
are not just created that music he took
boogie woogie
and put it you know and before rock and
roll things
swung swing music yeah
that was a group for swing rock and roll
right you got me moving over here daryl
yeah so he took that that swing music
you know in the blues and country and
put a bath beat on it that boogie woogie
with a back beat
right that became rock and roll and back
to the future
he call there's a scene when he when
michael j fox is playing
and i forget the guy's name but he says
you know that new sound you're looking
for
well get a listen to this boom and he
puts it in the guy oh wow
that's what that new sound was that's
great and michael j fox said
you might not be ready for this but your
kids are going to love it
right exactly you know it's prophetic
right right and just like the you know
chuck berry wrote a song called rock and
roll music
and everybody's covered everybody likes
that rock and roll
music right any old time you choose it
you use it yeah it's got a
what it's got a it's got a bat
beat you oh you gotta back okay all
right i just failed that test but i know
the song
yeah respect rock and roll music i love
that a
back beat you can't lose you got a bat
what are you talking about
ah that's the backbeat amazing
last question on music before we move on
to you know more serious topics
uh my favorite artist you know i love
all sorts of music i love sinatra i love
hip hop today
i love hall and oates i love you know
johnny good all that
um what are your thoughts on jackie
wilson
oh man one of the greatest singers of
all time
uh uh elvis loved him and in fact in las
vegas he was known as the black elvis
even though he was doing that before
right it's always
so i learned about jackie was i love old
movies i learned about jackie wilson
and for our audience that doesn't know
who he is there was a
famous scene in uh coming to america
eddie murphy
where he's shouting from the rooftops do
we love
to be loved oh what a feeling to be
loved
and i remember like these who is that
singer who is that person i found that
it was jackie wilson
and for some reason he's not as famous
as elvis
as chuck berry as james brown
why is that because he does he has so
many amazing songs
it's not for some reason there's a
reason why tell me why
the reason is racism you know you only
let a few
black people slip through the brats you
don't want too many of them
jackie wilson was a good looking uh
black guy yep
he had you know women went crazy over
him
right and white women were not immune to
that
you know some you know what's good
looking is good looking what sounds good
sounds good
regardless of color and you know and
that
that was a big concern back then little
richard got away with it
because little richard was gay so people
were not you know
so so worried about their women going
after you know this gay man
all right but you know you think about
it you think about like this also
when well when you know when i was
coming up
there were no black idols on tv uh
i you know who did i have to relate to i
had to relate to you to little opi
taylor
in mayberry you know andy griffiths and
opie didn't have any black friends
uh i watched leave it to beaver little
beaver cleaver and wally cleaver they
didn't have any black friends
i watched lost in space you know space
family robinson
with their crazy robot you know they
went all over the universe and he went
to other universes
and no black people no black people
they saw green people right there with
uh foreign aliens but not black people
you know how freaking absurd that is
yeah by today's standards yes but that's
what i had to grow up with all right
so then um the first
and there were no of course there were
no black superheroes that's why it was
it's such a big thing
that that this person would just die
black panther of course chadwick boseman
of course
exactly you know yeah so i mean who were
my heroes back then
batman superman aquaman you know wonder
woman
you know all these people but who what
were they all were white
right so so the i mean you you had
a couple or most shows that featured any
black people
they were in a subservient role as a
butler
you know the bottom right you know a
pimp a drug dealer in the movies or
whatever
but then you know when we got some
better roles
they were never top uh you know they're
always secondary
um so let's say i spy without bill cosby
and robert cook
partners in that in that tv series uh
but but one was not higher than the
other
uh then we saw lieutenant uhura in uh
starting the original star trek with uh
william shatner
and that was the first interracial kiss
on tv what year was that
i think 1969 right so all throughout the
60s there's nothing like that going on
exactly so into the 70s when did shaft
come out
uh shaft came out i think when maybe in
the late 70s
late 70s maybe mid to late 70s so who
was the first
you know you said there was only white
superheroes who was the first black
person you saw on tv you're like all
right i like that guy or a gal
oh yeah okay well he uh he he was a hero
uh he was a superhero like it was super
powers but he was a you know a badass
uh that was mr t mr t
yeah of course mr t but when was that
that was on the 18th what was that but
that was not until the early 80s though
right
exactly exactly it took up until the
early 80s until a superhero badass dude
showed up on the scene mr t
right exactly and what did they
pick for uh for that they picked the
ugliest black guy they could find
mr z yeah gold chains galore
yeah and his mohawk cars put
a denzel washington or a uh billy d
williams
or something you know good-looking black
guy up there because again that would
attract
you know the females and so you know you
know when what female in her right mind
is going to be attracted to mr g
mr t is not going to be happy when he
sees this daryl let me tell you
something
well i'll tell you what you know i i met
him one time and i was not very
impressed but uh you know that's a
different story all right
no worries so um no i appreciate we're
going all over the place here with with
music and everything
uh to kind of get back into things you
know your parents were very leery of
your ability
to make a living being a musician so
that's a good reason
right so tell me about that did you ever
have any doubts like what are your
thoughts on the financial
side of things being a musician i
never have any doubts about anything
that i do wow
not not because i'm an egotist but
because
my parents instilled that confidence in
me
and maybe that was a mistake on their
part you know they told me i could be
anything i'd like to be
and now so this is what i want to be
well now why are you telling me i can't
be it
it's too late you know you know you've
already brought me up this way you can't
you can't you can't uh
put this back into the can the bell has
been running
ring the bell gotcha amazing so
um can we stay on this financial topic
for a second
before we get into the kkk you know um
you know i host another show here on
valuetainment uh
on valuetainment economics where i'm all
about encouraging people
to save that money so basically make
your money
save it be financially smart um
[Music]
that's what i'm all about and it's no
secret that you know more
black people live in poverty more black
kids live in poverty than any other race
black wealth is far below white wealth
black home ownership is far below
you know white's um education black
owned businesses is something that needs
to be improved
what are your thoughts on the economic
empowerment that blacks need to
improve upon in america today well you
just hit the nail right on the head
everything you said is 100 true
and uh two things you know
are are affecting it uh both we can
change
one a little easier than the other one
is the uh racism of course that impacts
you know uh minorities especially uh
minorities of color
and uh black people and the other is uh
education
uh you know we uh we can change you know
we can we can self-educate
and and we can we can um seek out better
education
because in the inner city uh
we score very very low on sat scores
which is one of the things that the
client always points out to me when they
when they um you know want to put down
black people's intelligence
you know we're not as as uh as smart as
white people
you know they say we're prone to crime
uh and they evidenced that by
the higher number of blasting prisons
than white people
and that is true but of course it's not
so much that we're prone to crime
it's so much that there is an imbalance
of our judicial system as well
and plus as you point out the poverty
there are poor white people as well who
are in prison but plenty of black people
because they cannot afford
adequate legal representation and so
they end up taking a plea deal with
something
they didn't even do and now they're
stuck there uh
and then they say you know that black
people are born with a smaller brain
than white people and the larger the
brain the more room for capacity
of intelligence you know that's their
their line of thinking
and they evidenced that by the low s.a.t
scores that black people have that black
kids students have
of course they're not realizing that the
the school systems
in the inner city are not as good as the
school system in the suburb
which is why when we moved to boston it
was terrible
terrible so within a couple weeks we
moved out to the suburbs
so i could give a good education um but
i'll tell you this
it's not because somebody is black but
they're not intelligent
uh or don't have the higher sat scores
because when
when black kids are going to school in
the suburbs their scores
are just as high if not higher than
white kids and when white kids go to
school in the inner city guess what
their s.a.t scores are also low it's the
quality of education
not the color of skin of course it's the
environment that you grow up in right
precisely so so we need to focus more
on on getting better education because
racism is what uh it impacts us that you
know does not
try to let us go to the better schools
you know we're not bringing down
the standards you know you put us you
give us the same quality education that
you give everybody else
we will excel respect so
i have a whole uh list of questions on
the kkk obviously that's something
that you specialize in and uh before we
get to that let's just stay right here
on
on black americans you know you had
actually some very contentious
conversations with um
[Music]
with a handful of black people and this
is within the documentary and accidental
courtesy if you guys have not seen it
please check this out it's incredible a
couple young guys
it was an older guy and uh i think you
were in a bar or a restaurant you were
sitting at a table
and these guys would not shake your hand
they walked off on you they yelled at
you
why are black people so angry towards
those particular ones because i also
have a lot of black support clearly
clearly you have a lot of supporters
white black even green martians can
understand
what you're bringing to the table here
exactly uh because
ignorance ignorance you know uh
not being able to get up get out and
about and explore different people
and and find other ways of of combating
racism uh and here's the thing
um you were dealing in in that
particular scene
which took up about eight or nine
minutes in the movie right that scene
actually actually went on for just over
an
hour but of course we couldn't include
the whole hour of it
it almost became physical and you know
that that's that's how contentious it
was
who did it almost become physical with
uh
myself and and and the three of the
three people the two young guys
the two young guys as well as the older
guy because one of the guys said we're
about the same age buddy you know
and then there's the two younger guys
who felt like you were out of touch or
something
well they all did and uh because they
had not been exposed to the things that
they've been exposed to
their knowledge was very limited but i
can tell you this they you know
they were the baltimore chapter of black
lives matter
and and i don't want to paint a broad
brush because
uh black lives matter is not an
organization it's a movement
and there are many many over 90 factions
across the country
of this movement and they each are
individuals some are comprised of black
supremacists
some are comprised of predominantly
white people some are comprised of
black and white some have an agenda of
aggression
uh others have an agenda hey then let's
sit down and try to work this out and
drop some
some legal bills and pass etc so you
have all different
matters um there are about five or six
chapters
across the country that have contacted
me and said hey do you give workshops
can you teach us how to do what you do
and then there are other chapters who
simply just rip me a new one
because you know they can't stand me
because i'm sitting down talking with
the enemy
i'm talking with the oppressors and
things like that i'm treating them
with respect the fact that i treat them
with respect i treat anybody with
respect
okay until they put their hands on me
then it's a whole new ballgame
but while you know people have we have
to respect
someone's right to say what they want to
say we don't have to respect what they
say
but let's respect their right to say it
because if you want to be heard
you have to you have to hear the other
people too you don't have to agree with
them
but you must give them a chance to to
voice their opinions
and that's what i do because once
they're heard
and i allow them to be heard rather than
shut them down
and push back then when when they are
heard
their wall comes down and they feel
compelled now hey
this guy my enemy let me you know let me
save my peace even though i'm insulting
him to his face
so now their wall is down and they
reciprocate and allow me to save my
peace
when i say my peace they're hearing me
because their defense mechanism is down
you know but when it's up you can talk
all you want it's just you know
they're like this it's just a brick wall
so i allow them to speak
in that space and then they allow me to
be to be heard
and that's when they go home and think
about what i've said
and it works on them and over time they
realize you know what i didn't change my
direction
that's how people change you know you
can legislate all day long
you can legislate and compel somebody's
behavior
but you cannot legislate somebody's
feelings
i mean just just like you know the the
bus boycott right white people did not
want us in the front of the bus
uh you know when when the law changed
they know that we could sit wherever we
wanted to sit
that compelled them to let us sit there
even though they didn't like it they
didn't feel that we should sit there
they had to abide by the law otherwise
they'd be the one in jail not rosa parks
so respect a willingness to less a
willingness to listen well let me put it
this way
between traveling as a child and now as
an adult musician
around the world i have been in 57
different countries
on six continents so i've been exposed
exposed to a multitude
of ethnicities colors of skin cultures
traditions
religions you name it and
no matter how far i've gone from this
country no matter how
different a person may look or
or their culture may be from mine i've
concluded at the end of the day
we all are human beings and we all want
basically the same
four or five things no matter how far
away we are in this country
we want to be loved we want to be
respected
we want to be treated fairly we want to
be heard
and we want the same things for our
family as anybody else wants for their
family
and if we can understand those simple
simple five
human things no matter what culture we
go into
no matter how far away from our own
country we can navigate
that culture so if you view white
supremacists
as simply another culture and you apply
those five things you will you will make
a connection
you will be able to navigate with them
and be able to have discourse
civil discourse that's some powerful
stuff right there daryl
well okay what you know i've proven that
it works
yes you have and so uh i'm not knocking
what anybody else does because there are
many facets to racism
and what they do they're addressing you
know one facet
of the police and systemic racism etc
and that's great you know that needs to
be done also
but we also need to address the
individual racists
and that's what i do i sit down and have
a heart to heart
face to face head to head talk with them
right
with the keys with them not about them
not at them
not past them but with them and that's
what creates
change that's awesome that's a great
segue to obviously jumping into that
side of things just so
before we move on to that i want to
recap what you just said
because i don't want to just jump right
over that everyone
in the world craves these five things
yes right to be loved to be respected
to be treated fairly to be
heard and everyone wants the same thing
for their family
those five things yeah did i say that
right
absolutely everything everybody wants to
send it to their family as you want for
yours
respect and that's how you're able
with that state of mind that's how
you're able to sit down with these
racist kkk members and hear them
and listen to them yeah let me give you
an example of something
please do that actually happens okay so
when
when one of these guys walks into a room
with me
and sees me their wall goes right up
because i am the enemy i am black
just because you're black you are the
enemy absolutely
bios joined the king akk right right you
know i mean
what was the kkk all about you know they
they didn't like black people right you
know black members there
so that wall goes right up when they see
the enemy and they're ready to attack
so i'm sitting there two feet away from
the person
interviewing them and i'm asking you
know how do you hate you know you don't
even know me all you see is this caller
my scan
well and then as i pointed out they tell
you well you know
black people are prone to crime all you
have to do is look at the prison system
they're more blasting than white people
you know black people are lazy you know
they don't want to work they prefer to
scam the government welfare system
um and black people you know are not as
intelligent as white people
they're born with a smaller brain all
you have to do is there's a few sats
scores mr davis
you know black students consistently
every year these who are lower than
white people
are these the consistent talking points
of everyone in the kkk
you're prone to violence you're not as
smart as me
um sat scores this kind of thing
yes because yeah that's that's the
narrative that they're they teach their
members
when you come in those are the talking
points because when you repeat it enough
times
it becomes the truth wow in their minds
you know one's perspective is one's
reality
all right so i'm sitting there
you know to them so when they walk in
the room and there i am
that wall goes up they're ready to pass
so
usually when you when you're telling
somebody things like that
you know you're talking to your
adversary and and you are calling him
a criminal uh lazy being on welfare
and telling him he's not as intelligent
as you are because his brain is smaller
and things like that is that offensive
of course that's offensive
am i offended by it absolutely not wow
but why why am i not offended by it
because it's not right yeah exactly why
would i be offended by a lie
but too many people let their emotions
get in front of them wow
and then they start pushing back and and
when you push back against a wall
like guess what the wall usually wins
all right you know
you hit that brick wall you're not going
through it you know they're not hearing
what you have to say
because you're pushing back they are
accustomed to that push back
because they are offending you all the
time and and so
you know see they see somebody who was
jewish
somebody who is black somebody who was
muslim somebody who was gay
these are people they don't like or
somebody white with a black person
that's like a race traitor somebody you
know they don't like
so they go on the attack and within 45
seconds
they're getting pushed back so they're
accustomed to that you see their verbal
pushback
or physical so they are accustomed to it
but now guess what
i'm sitting two feet in front of them
listening to them
allowing them to be heard and so
i'm throwing them off their game that
because they're not
they're expecting you to fight they're
expecting you to overreact
and you just how do you actually not
you know react in a in a negative way
how do you sit there and take that what
is that about you in your dna
that you're like all right buddy all
right i see what you're saying you're
not talking about me
they're not talking about me and you
have to understand i mean they think
they are
but i know better how do they know me
they just met me five ten minutes ago
now if my mother or father would tell me
daryl you know i you know i think you're
prone to crime
you know you know you you're very lazy
and you're not that smart
if if my parents were to tell you that i
might take a little more
you know uh acceptance of what they had
to say
because they brought me into this world
they raised me but not somebody who just
met me
ten five ten minutes ago no i'm not
listening to that i'll listen to it but
it rolls off my back and plus you've got
to understand my background again
my parents were diplomats you know we go
into foreign countries that have
policies and traditions and laws that
don't
you know merge with our own and my dad's
job
was to foster better relations with the
foreign country
with the us so you have to listen to
those people and listen to them
and try to understand where they're
coming from and then
you know you have these conversations so
here's the key
you cannot convince anybody of anything
when that wall is up all right you need
to lower the temperature
bring that wall down and then they hear
you because when the wall is up there
like this
all right so when i when i am listening
to them
showing them that respect allowing them
to be heard
all right that wall is coming down
and when the wall gets down then they
they feel compelled
to reciprocate and allow you to be heard
because after all you gave them you know
you know that respect and that uh
allowing them to be heard you give them
their platform so now they don't give
you yours
so i could go on the attack at that
point because their wall is down you
don't know nothing you can't you can't
tell me nothing that kind of a thing
exactly you're the one who's a criminal
because you're the one who's hanging
black men from trees you're the one
walking walking into black churches
and shooting people and bombing their
churches are burning down their homes
uh you know dragging black people behind
pick up trucks which you naturally
don't say right right do you ever want
to say that do you ever want to say
yes of course i do but you hold it back
because because
because it's true these things did
happen and this still happened
okay yeah so it's true i could i would
be well within my right to say that
all right but no if i do that that wall
starts going back up i want to keep the
wall down so they hear what i have to
say
so rather than go on the offense i stay
on the defense
and what i say is you know i hear what
you're saying
but please consider this i don't have a
criminal record
nobody in my family has a criminal
record
i have never been on welfare nobody in
my family's been on welfare
i've never measured my brain size but
i'm sure it's the same size as anybody
else's and as far as
sat scores go my sats
got me into college i have a college
degree
now i say that knowing that that person
sitting two feet in front of me
barely made it out of high school if he
did all right
and i know that i have more intelligence
in my little fingernail than he and his
whole clan
put together but i'm not gonna throw
that in his face
because if i did that wall goes back up
so
let me tell you so let's see what
happens then okay so
you know rather than attack with all
those facts that i have
i just defended them and that because
that way he hears them
and he can process them he doesn't hear
anything with him when his wall is up
so i can tell you this for a fact not an
opinion a fact
because years later months later
whatever
when they when they uh renounce that
ideology and give it up and give you
their rubs and hoods and stuff
here's what what i found out has
happened multiple times with these
people
they go home and they think about what
transpired
during the day and they're like damn you
know i just had a three-hour
conversation with the black guy
three hours and we didn't fight you know
we disagreed but we didn't fight
you know and and what he said about such
and such you know that makes sense
but he's black um but but what he said
was true
oh but he's black so they're having this
cognitive dissonance going on
you know they realize something is true
but it came from a black source so that
is not computed
you know and so it leaves him with a
dilemma
and the dilemma is i know this to be
true
so should i disregard his skin color
and believe the truth and change my
direction or should i consider his skin
color
and keep on living a lie that becomes
their dilemma
and eventually many of them
go the right way and they believe the
truth and they renounce and they change
there will always be those who will go
to their graves being hateful
racist and violent but see that's why i
say i plant the seed i have the impetus
for them to change themselves i don't
like to say that i converted them
i just gave them a reason to think about
it and they convert themselves
and that was in the introduction that's
what i said is that you're the spark
that that causes them to go back and sit
at home and be like
damn like yeah this guy just blew my
mind he was
he was smart he was cool we got along he
plays the hell out of a keyboard a piano
you can do the twist you can do it all
and i can't
[Laughter]
so you blow their mind a little bit and
they go home
to their wife to their kids to whatever
and
what do you think they're going through
at that like that night right because
this might be the first time they're
really
interacting with a black person and a
cool black guy
and a smart guy are they are they
thinking man
is my whole life a lie and what have i
been doing
like what do you think is actually going
on in these kkk members heads
that just causes them to say what is
going on here
because i can tell you exactly what they
told me you know and now we're friends
and some of them even come out with me
on the speaking circuit and speak with
them on the same stage and
and renounce you know their formal
organization what goes through their
mind is
you know how uh depends upon what they
have invested in the group if they're
just a rank-and-file member
you know um they don't have a lot
invested
uh so they're easier to get out if they
are a leader
that means they have followers so what
goes to their mind also is
man you know how do i tell all these
people that i was wrong
oh and that's very powerful and they go
and do that and say you know i'm leaving
you know i decided
you know hey guys you know this is wrong
this is not right i've been just leaving
you
and and you feel like it's easier to
plant that seed in a rank and file
member versus a leader is that
of course because you know what when you
are a leader you are powerful
and no matter what organization you are
in
racist or non-racist um political or
non-political
when you are in when you are sitting on
the throne of power
you don't want to get off
nobody wants to give up power let's go
back to music
if you have a number one song number one
platinum you don't want to see it drop
down to number two and then
on number three and then fall off the
top 100 you want to stay at number one
for as long as you can
of course okay so they're number one
when they're a leader
they're not number one in the world or
in your world or my world but they're
number one in their own little bubble in
their level
they have all these followers that look
under them
how do you tell all those followers hey
you know what i was wrong
and have leaders actually done that so
so here's my question
you know you've you've convinced what a
couple hundred klansmen to give up their
cloak and robe whether directly or
indirectly right
right um well they convinced themselves
i just gave them the reason correct
you're the spark that that causes them
to go down this path of enlightenment
almost
um what do those leaders
those leaders say to the followers like
meaning
there's a difference between a guy
saying you know what i just met daryl
that guy blew my mind i'm going to quit
the kkk
i'm just a rank and file guy i'm going
to keep moving all of my life
versus the leader that has to maybe
speak to
his constituents and say guys i got a
breaking news for everybody
i'm out yeah walk me through that
thought process
okay uh it goes it happens a few
different ways
uh some just say hey you know what i'm
um i'm retiring i'm
i'm stepping down i'm retiring yeah
uh now if they retire um
and still have those beliefs that
they take the the rank of giant okay
grand mean state level imperial means
national level
so a state leader is known as a grand
dragon a national leader is known as an
imperial wizard
so if they retire because you know they
can't do it anymore they can't they
can't march anymore they're
you know they have knee operation or
just old and whatever else
uh they need to get out but they still
have they still believe white supremacy
then then they are it's like you know we
would say president or ex-president
former president
so a former grand dragon who still has
those beliefs
becomes a grand giant an imperial wizard
becomes an imperial giant
giant means retired but still of the
faith
okay um so then there are those who
retire
uh and and don't have those feelings
anymore they leave and they go quietly
because if they start talking bad about
their organization
there may be some ramifications because
you know what when you join that
organization you take a blood oath
all right what type of ramifications
could they face
uh i'll tell you what look up a guy
named david lynch not david lynch the
movie maker
but david lynch just put in david lynch
neo-nazi white supremacist
he was a friend of mine he was he he
formed the largest skinhead movement in
the country
and uh vehemently uh violent and racist
and medic everything and he and i became
friends he got out of the movement
and he testified against some of his own
members
uh somebody went into his home while he
was sleeping and blew its head off
that doesn't happen all the time but yes
that can't happen and and what you have
to understand is you know
uh when you join these things that
becomes your family it's like a cult
that becomes your family above and
beyond all others
you don't betray family you want to go
away quietly then be quiet
um but you don't you know come into the
family and then
you know talk bad about them after you
leave wow you know they might come after
you
now daryl there's this gentleman david
lynch who
uh you referred to him as your friend
now i know obviously in a lot of your um
in your interviews and in the
documentary you refer to a lot of these
kkk klansmen as your friend
so here's my question are they really
your friends or are they more
acquaintances you get along with
both uh i have acquaintances that get
along and i have friends
and you know you don't always have to
agree with your friends you know you
might have a
you know you might be pro-abortion and
your friend is you know uh pro-choice or
whatever your pro
pro-choice or um or pro-life or whatever
uh but you find other things to agree
upon
you know and the more you talk the more
you begin to humanize your other person
and you might see their point of view or
your point of view etc
that's how things you find commonalities
that way
even though you start out as adversaries
the more you talk
that gap narrows so your adversary's
here
and as you find more and more common
avenues and conversations you're here
you are forming a relationship at that
point
you talk some more and that that even
gets closer
because you found more commonalities by
the time you get here
you have a friendship all right you may
not agree on everything but you have a
friendship
at this point in time the trivial things
that you have in contrast
such as skin color or whether you go to
a church
a temple a mosque or a synagogue begin
to matter less and less
wow would you say that would you say
today
you have more black friends white
friends
latino friends female friends all the
above is there any differentiating all
the above
no depth at the mall no difference to me
no difference to me
uh and you know and i i thank my parents
you know you know for that background
a couple uh stories i want to ask you
about speaking of your friends
there was one uh instance where uh
i believe it was in maryland the grand
dragon roger kelly
you two became so close he named you the
godfather of his daughter
yes and uh now there's a um
post group to that um yeah he did and
but you know uh his uh his wife's
brother or whatever
uh wanted you know wanted that position
and and that side of the family was a
little
little you know upset about that so i
just said
i can imagine if a klansman family yeah
double d over here he's going to be the
uh godfather
so i i really push that another story
this this
this this is actually very apropos a
clans woman named
tina puig um
and once you told her hey shut up and
listen
and she eventually did and you drove her
and her family to see her husband in
jail if i understand it correctly
and she came back after essentially
hating you
initially she said you believes and i
quote
god does work through people and he most
certainly uses daryl davis
as an instrument yes do you believe that
do you believe god uses you as an
instrument
to do what you do i do believe so i do
believe he has a very strong hand in it
because
i've been in situations that i should
not have walked out of wow
on two feet yeah and what instrument
would you be
being that you're a musician a uniter
a uniter and music unites people
of course we covered that um
another another a couple other stories
at one point you walked a clans lady
down the aisle and you served as her you
know
father surrogate father uh tell me about
that
okay so this uh let's go back to
three years ago uh last month
charlottesville virginia
where they had a white supremacist large
white supremacist rally
and um heather heyer i believe was the
other higher was murdered there by a
white supremacist
uh there were many many scenes of
violence that day
all over downtown charlottesville one of
the scenes
uh depicted some clansmen coming down
the steps
of a uh confederate park i remember
swinging flat you know confederate
flagpoles of this black guy
who at the same time was trying to torch
them with an improvised uh flamethrower
and aerosol can i remember that
whatever okay yeah so the leader of that
imperial wizard um had just come down
the steps
and he turned around and saw the scene
going on
and he pulled a gun and pointed it at
the black guy's head
and shouted hey [ __ ] and then he
lowered the gun and fired it
and the bullet went into the ground near
the black guy's feet
and then the imperial wizard turned and
walked away right past the charleston
police were standing there watching the
whole thing go down
and did absolutely nothing as a result
of them of their of their inaction and
also other inactions that day
the police chief of charlottesville was
fired and replaced
as as he should have been uh anyway
um so you know i was thinking you know
what on earth uh what you know what
would you do
if you saw that in your city and and too
many americans think oh you know
i live in los angeles or i live in boise
idaho
you know i live in dallas texas you know
that you know charlottesville
and that's their problem yeah you know
that's not here but i'll tell you what
um anywhere there's hate that can happen
it can happen in any city usa
and furthermore any city usa if you are
an american
is your city you can only you put your
head down
on a pillow in one city at a time but
but you own all those cities if you live
in dallas
austin is also your city so is el paso
so is los angeles so is oregon oregon
these are all american cities and you're
an american this is your country so what
problems charlottesville has
you have because it's your country so
what are you going to do
well the first thing people want to do
is blame somebody else
all right so we could blame the the
klansmen coming down the stairs
and trying to hit somebody with the
flagpole yeah they should not have been
doing that
they get some blame uh we can blame the
black guy if we're trying to torch
somebody
he should not have been doing that so he
gets some blame we can blame the uh clan
leader
for pulling out a gun and firing it he
should definitely not have been doing
that
but you know what we can blame the
police for not doing their job
you know they're paid by us taxpayers to
serve and protect
who are they serving who are who are
they protecting that day certainly not
anybody there and damn sure not heather
higher
okay so they weren't doing their job
they definitely give some blame
but maybe we ought to blame ourselves
for allowing
our country to come to that point in the
21st century
but you know what sitting around because
every time you blame somebody they're
gonna blame somebody else or they're not
blaming you that
so so blaming is a waste of time all
right
um maybe what we should do is
is focus our energy on doing something
constructive
rather than just passing blame around
that's a waste of time
uh realize that our country
can only become one of two things
one it can become that which we sit back
and let it become or it can be that
which we stand up and make it become
so we have to ask ourselves the question
do i want to sit back
and see what my country becomes or do i
want to stand up
and make my country become what i want
to see so
i chose the latter i'm going to stand up
and make this country become what i want
to see
because i have to live here my future
has to live here
whoever comes after me so i called that
guy
up the shooter and i said look man
i said you and i need to talk i knew who
he was you know beforehand
i said you and i need to talk not uh
plans from the black man
but man to man american to american your
confederate history
is as much a part of my history as my
black history is a part of yours
let's you and i explore american history
together
i want to hear what you have to say he
said
okay so we set a date i drove an hour
and a half and a half to his home
by myself and i go into his home
like kkk stuff all over the walls and
favorite stuff
i sat on a confederate flag blanket on
this couch
you know and i listened to him give me
a lesson in american history from a
confederate you know standpoint of
course
what city was he in by the way uh he's
up in maryland okay
and uh and so uh anyway about an hour
and a half from where i live
and so i listened to this for two and a
half hours uh but i don't have
actually a little bit less about two
hours um and he got some things right he
got something wrong
but i just sat back and i listened you
listened to
so essentially nonsense for two hours
exactly
exactly but this goes back to your whole
point you have to sit can listen if you
want to be respected
bring the wall down right i'm going to
let him have his peace
all right so what what's going is it off
my back
you know not it's just a little bit of
time that's all wow so
you're coolness under pressure and and
when he was done
i corrected him on the things that he
got wrong
and commended him on the things that he
got right and then it's my turn to
present my peace
again rather than attack i said you know
what
let's do this let's set a date because
his
fiance the clan's lady was also there
and um i said let's
set a date i'd like for you all to come
down to my house
and service friend and um and i would
drive you both
down to washington dc which is only 15
minutes from me
and i will it will go to the uh to the
new
smithsonian national museum of african
american history and culture
and which is about maybe 30 minutes from
me and
uh let's just take a tour of it and say
okay
so i've been there by the way that is
amazingly powerful stuff right there so
i can imagine when he saw some of the
stuff that's in there
his mind must have opened up a little
bit right and then he has to think about
it again when he goes home he just let
it you know
let it soak in so um you know we go down
you know so he comes down to the house
we hang out my living room with his
fiancee
and then um you know we go on down to
the museum
and we toured for all almost three hours
a short of three hours
and uh and then we leave and
um you know this is uh almost you know a
year later
the incident uh with the shooting was
august 12
uh 2017 and um
and so this is in june of 2018
and so a few weeks thereafter he's going
to get he's going to marry that lady
and she's from chattanooga tennessee
so her um so i get invited to the
wedding
and again which is a first you know not
only for me
you get invited to this kkk wedding
that's exactly
because you know by that time listen you
don't invite enemies to your wedding do
you
what do you invite you invite your
friends right he considered me a friend
wow you know now you know so he was
changing
he was in the process of changing all
right so
an active verb and so i can say you know
we started out here
you know you know hey [ __ ] boom is not
a friend exactly
the gap is closing i've been working
with him now for almost a year
right he's beginning to respect me
humanize me see things that i want him
to see
i listen to him he listens to me that
kind of thing so that gap is closing
it closed so much that he invites me to
his wedding
all right so then um
her that not only is that her first for
me that's the first for the kkk
all over all right and of course he
thought he got some flaps for that
which is good but i'll tell you about
that in a second um
so her father down in tennessee
was too ill or whatever to make it up to
his daughter's wedding to escort her
down the aisle guess who gets asked
right so what am i gonna say no i'm a
friend
so i say yeah sure i i don't care what
people think about me
i've already proven that if you saw in
the movie no you're you're just doing
what daryl do
like this you're just doing you wow
so um i did it you know
and um it made national news
and other kkk groups all over the place
he put in some of his own
saw it the ones who weren't thinking
once we were there saw it in person
but one's all over the place because i
asked him if it would be okay
if cnn came yeah and um hey can cnn come
to your wedding
yeah i asked him and uh you know i i
would never mislead him you know he's my
friend
and he said yeah he said um i don't care
about me you know
and my clans lady um you know you show
our faces we just ask them not to show
the faces of the other clan people you
know
he don't want them to lose their jobs or
whatever and um
as a leader you know he has to be out
there so his face is already known just
just not not to cut you off but
something you just said was actually
mind-blowing because you don't want them
to lose their jobs let's not forget
these are regular people they have jobs
right they're
they're you know they're waiters they're
they're cooks they're police officers
they're firemen
they're construction workers they're in
our community it's not like they're just
living within the kkk all day every day
they meet what you know weekly monthly
what have you and then they go back out
into the real world
plans man it's just a it's just a title
like boy scout leader
you have to have a real job wow
okay so um so you know they understood
that they said okay fine
so no filming of the faces right of of
the of the members
so ah you know they didn't film the
faces
and um i walked down the aisle i gave
her away
and uh of course so that was seen all
over the world
on cnn and um that of course
caused a major ripple and and
and planted them if you will and he and
she began receiving hate mail
calling her and calling her and he a uh
a race trainer
how could you let a [ __ ] come to your
wedding and that
i even kissed her on the cheek when i
gave her away um
you know that that was just mind-blowing
for a lot of people
not only in the plan but also outside of
the plan and
so that was a good thing because it was
kind of a bittersweet thing for him
because
here he is a clan leader and now all the
hate that he was radiating
out was now coming back at him
oh all because a black guy had
had hair upon his arm and walked down
the aisle so now he's seeing the
reflection
the mirror you know and that gives him
pause for thought like
wow is this really what i want to be
involved in
like i'm used to giving so much hate now
i'm receiving it this is what it feels
like
the shoes on the other foot that's what
i mean
but to use your word sparking something
okay and you know it takes a while
in this case it took a year almost a
year like i said
from august 2017 he got married in july
of 2018. so almost a year you know one
month short of a year
um but you know what that's if that's
what it takes that's what it takes
but consider it this way he had this
hatred and
rage in him for many many years
all right so if it can all go away
within one year that's a short period of
time right
you had once said that um i don't want
to
misquote you you had said you know
things don't happen overnight
and you pointed to this fine figure of
yours right here
and you said i want to lose uh i want to
lose it yeah lose some weight
right uh and i'm but i know i'm not
going to lose it tomorrow
but if i work on it over time it'll
shrink down is that basically what that
story
was right there yeah that reflects that
story absolutely
but you know there are other ones
similar in the plan you know
like roger kelly becoming an imperial
wizard he had a wide following
giving up and not only not only did he
give up the ideology
he did not turn his clan over to his
second in command
he shut it down he shut down his grip
wow it's a big difference between just
you know sitting here i don't believe it
anymore you go ahead and take it over
no he said you know what this ends here
the um speaking of shutting it down
um i believe you had met with the
the representative of the southern
poverty law
center and they had they
what's that who does not like me does
not like you
no i don't think so okay so that's my
question right he says that basically
they have a wholesale strategy to ending
racism in the kkk while yours is a
retail strategy
um what do you think is more effective
and to
to you know not to put words in your
mouth why does it do you think
he likes you you guys have the same
agenda explain that wholesale retail
strategy
and why someone with the same agenda
would not like you
well same thing with the blm guys in the
movie
we have the same agenda you know more or
less to
to to do away with racism um but uh we
have different methods of doing it
and this is what we have to learn you
know racism is multi-faceted
and there and there's no there's no one
one size fits all
uh method of of uh of diminishing it
you know there are many different
aspects that we have to address
we have to we do things my way we do
things their way
but what's important is that we
coordinate
our efforts you do what you specialize
in what he specializes
when he specializes in the guy from the
southern public law center
he specializes in the legal uh aspect of
it
and what can i do to to legally compel
them to do something
i'm gonna hit them in the wallet by
suing them
and making them you know give up all
kinds of money and give up their charter
and give up their buildings and
whatever else and that that will bring
them down
yes that is effective it also brings
more resentment and more anger
and all they do is simply rebrand and
come out more ferociously
because now they've been hurt um what i
try to do is try to make them think you
know what
there's a better way and you can have a
better life
you know because hate is exhausting you
know and all you're doing is just
exhausting yourself
you know so um you know wouldn't it
wouldn't it be better to to have
somebody come to their own conclusion
i've been wrong i need to change
rather than you know make me change by
but
it cost me my job and cost me all kinds
of money yes people need to be punished
for things they do
when they hurt somebody else so yes they
should be punished
um but we also have to to help somebody
reform
their ways sort of like the difference
between
a reformatory and a prison prison does
not reform
prison only penalizes that's why that's
why
in this country we have a high rate of
recidivism
and so we know that we've known that for
hundreds of
hundreds of years you know because
you send somebody to prison uh you hope
that the time spent
in there they will think about what
they're doing and then when they're
released
you know they won't want to come back uh
but but uh reality proves that chances
are they will come back
you know there are those who who go
there once and now
that's not for me i'm gonna walk the
straight and narrow and they walk the
straight and they are fine
but but there is a higher rate of
recidivism in this country than anywhere
else
and that's because we don't reform them
in prison
and when you when you've seen that for
decades you begin to wonder
why is there no reform in prison well
you know why
because somebody's making money and the
more people come back
the more money you make wow it's the
money play
yeah it's sort of like the uh the
pharmaceutical companies
we know there are cures out there but if
i cure some disease
nobody's gonna be buying my medicine
anymore and daryl that's some powerful
stuff right there
but you know it's true of course you
know i think
the united states has four percent of
the world's population
but 25 of the world's prisoners
does that's that makes sense to you um
i don't know the exact numbers but yes
the analogy makes sense yes absolutely
it's crazy
it's uh but the embassy but we're based
on a society
of money and greed you know how much
money can i make
even if i have to make it off off of
somebody
you know and not help them yeah i'm
helping myself well you're very
pro-american i've gotten that stance
absolutely you're very pro-american
yes i am and which is why i'm doing this
but uh
it's where i live uh but at the same
time i
i also am willing to admit uh the faults
of our country you know we we we all
have history
the good the bad the uh we have the
shameful and it all
needs to be displayed and those things
that reflect negatively
need to be addressed we cannot change
our history we cannot change what we've
done
but we can take where we are and change
our future
you said um you can make up for past
mistakes you said that um
to recap what you said that yes part of
our history is shameful
um but you don't burn our history down
regardless of how good or bad or ugly it
is kkk
the kkk is as american as baseball apple
pie
and chevrolet it's an ugly part of our
history
because it is american it was created
right here it was born and bred and
still exists it's an american
institution of the institution but
that's what it is
and so you know we need to learn from it
why do we have
the uh the holocaust museum should we
just destroy that
because the holocaust ended in 1945 and
let's not talk about it anymore
no because it's bound to repeat itself
if you don't
let's learn from what happened at the
holocaust so that is never repeated
well not even 100 years from now the um
have you ever seen my father who grew up
in detroit
and my grandparents also in detroit they
used to tell me they would see
signs that said no blacks no jews
no dogs yeah you've seen this before
growing up ever i haven't seen the
actual signs but i've seen pictures of
them yes
yeah and i'll tell you what uh
in 1993 uh
during the first gulf war right
i played at a place in baltimore with a
friend of mine
um it was his gig and uh he was he
needed a piano player so
i went that was off that night went up
there
and um you know usually you load in the
back door of a place because you're
bringing in equipment and stuff
um so i pulled in the back parking lot
came through the back door the stage is
right there and i put my keyboard there
and whatever else
and uh you know played that you did and
uh i i had not seen the front of the
place other than from the stage
so on break i went it was hot in there i
went outside i walked up the front door
and um you know i'm hanging out the
sidewalk just getting some fresh air or
whatever
and then when it's time to go back in i
go to go back in
and right there on the front door
is a sign a piece of paper somebody had
written on there
the management um uh
no no no no shirts no snow
no no shoes um no sand monkeys
no service yeah
1993 1993 this is where we're at
you're very pro-american i'm wondering
what are your thoughts on capitalism
when done in moderation it has its
values
when done to excess it becomes breed it
becomes
stuff destructive in the in the long run
it's all about you know what you know
what can i get for myself the bigger the
better
and that's not always the case you know
we know everything you need to be in
moderation
how how is what i believe in going to
affect
everybody else as opposed to how is what
i believe in
gonna gonna benefit just me and my
family
interesting um you and curt you
you had mentioned um you know speaking
outside of the united states now
traveling uh you said you'd been to 57
countries
six continents i assume the one
continent you have not been to
is antarctica but i truly believe if
there are racist
uh whales or uh seals in uh antarctica
you would have a heart-to-heart with
them and listen to them
and change their hearts and minds um so
you've executed
you can't have racist penguins because
they're they're like black and white did
you
imagine if there's some racist penguins
they're self-doubting they don't know
what's going on
um but um hate is exhausting
for sure why is traveling so
okay that takes me to my favorite quote
of all time
and it's by mark twain otherwise known
by his real name of samuel samuel
clemens
and it's called the travel quote by mark
twain
and no truer words have ever been spoken
what mark twain said was
travel is fatal to prejudice prejudice
bigotry and narrow-mindedness
and many of our people need it sorely on
these accounts
broad wholesome charitable views of men
and things
cannot be acquired by vegetating in one
little corner of the earth
all one's lifetime and that is so true
and i i have benefited so much from
traveling
and seeing different people and you know
and here's the thing with us
as americans everybody everywhere i go
um i won't say everybody but a lot of
other people
are bilingual trilingual and even
speak four languages my dad spoke nine
languages yeah uh but most americans
only speak one language
english that's it you know and
unfortunately
most americans do not travel um
in fact less than 50 percent of
americans
have their passport um europeans travel
all the time they're always going
somewhere
and and most of them not all of them of
course but most of them
especially in uh in urban cities uh
speak more than one language
so you know in europe most uh most
people in the urban cities
uh are bilingual they speak another
language uh and you know if you have in
the rural parts of the country
they speak their national language and
perhaps a dialect something like that
but most americans only speak english
you know and
it is hindering you know when you want
to travel but
i realize that that most americans black
or white
uh have not had the travel experience
that i've had
that does not make me a better person
than anybody else
it simply makes gives me a broader
perspective of course than most
would you say that most uh kkk members
have never been out of the united states
yes most of them have not uh some have
been
through the military things like that
and
a lot of them don't even travel in their
own country let alone their own
state you know yeah
bubble homogenous you know go see your
country
go to the grand canyon you know go see
the lincoln memorial you know go do
something
um and you know america yeah you know
you you're gonna be pro-america but yet
but yet you won't leave
leave your little town in your state you
know as an american this is all your
country
and we are all your people you get to
know us
you know uh so that's you know that's
the ignorance and here's another thing
that's interesting
um we talked about you know a big thing
right now there's a confederacy
it's always been big in there you know
in their minds but here here's what
what you might find very very funny
comical
uh is the clan in the southern states
oh man they're all about that
confederate flag and the confederate
monuments
that's my heritage my great grandfather
you know fought in the
in the confederacy but guess what so did
mine
because anybody who knows american
history
knows there are plenty of blacks that
fought in the confederacy
because slaves had to fight for their
slave masters
oh actually yeah okay so
uh while i was born in chicago my
parents are from virginia
and virginia was the seat of the
confederacy
so my answer was fought my slave answers
was fought in the confederacy
now that does not mean that they honor
the confederacy or they honor
slavery you know they have to do they
were slaves um but now here's the thing
so these people want to honor their
great great ancestors for the
confederacy
whatever the clans in the northern
states
they don't fly the confederate flag
because they won't honor the confederacy
because they had uh their their grand
ancestors
fought in the union and they were killed
by people in the confederacy
so why am i going to honor the
confederacy
right so even though they have the same
agenda
anti-black anti-jewish anti-whatever
they're anti-each other when it comes to
the confederacy
so do they butt heads regarding that is
that something that cert do clans
do certain clan members fight over
certain things yes absolutely
absolutely um and here's the interesting
thing you know when you hate somebody
else you basically hate yourself
uh clan groups are are all rivals with
one another
sometimes they try to put together a
confederation of clan groups
but it doesn't last very long in the
beginning there was
one plan one plan and chapters of that
plan
spread all over the place today there is
no such thing as
the ku klux klan there are many ku klux
klan groups
it's a decentralized organization
because of all the infighting and you
know you know we're the real clan you
know that's a wannabe clan
you know that's a plan that lets black
people come to their wedding you know
that kind of thing
the clan is decentralized kind of like
how you said on the blm with
decentralized well blm is not an
organization
it's a movement you know you know you
don't pay dues to it you know and all
that kind of
you know now uh speaking of those guys
from the movie you know a year later
they reached out to me
and we got together and made amends um
but are you members of blm you're
talking about
you're the ones in the movie wow the two
young guys
yeah well one of the two young guys
couldn't couldn't make the dinner
but the other one did and and the older
guy and we got together we had dinner
and we talked and we agreed to work
together and uh and we you know patched
up the differences
and then um just late last year
uh the older guy fell off the wagon
again and reverted back to
through this former self and why was
that what what happened with that
gentleman or why would someone
you know consider changing and then fall
back and
what is that ignorance you know just
couldn't handle it
it all comes down to respect and a
willingness to listen those are the keys
yes did i say that right you did i don't
respect what you are saying
but i respect your right to say them
you're right
these are daryl davis quotes ladies and
gentlemen i know you're very big on face
to face you've actually said
you can't know the real me through
facebook or through email
or on a phone call you got to sit across
from somebody
and meeting someone is very essential
you know it's like you know you know
going on dating sites or
or meeting somebody in person you know
yeah so
now with today everything digital we're
on zoom right now
covid we can't meet up how has that
changed or impacted what you do
physically it's impacted me because as a
musician as a lecturer
i'm always on the road i'm always
traveling going somewhere to perform
or to speak and at this point in time so
you know it was very unsettling
you know it's like my my feet are moving
around but i'm not going anywhere i'm in
my house
and uh i have not been in at home
this many consecutive days in a row
since i was a kid living with my parents
or something
you know that's how much i traveled and
so
it's definitely been a change but i've
been productive
i finished writing my second book i
started my own podcast not as extensive
as yours anybody else's
but just something i thought i would do
i've interviewed a lot of interesting
people that i've met over the years
in my life musicians white supremacists
psychologists you know whatever
rwandan genocide survivors people like
that and um
i'm learning to use uh you know modern
technology
like we're doing right now yes we are
i'm i'm by no means a zoom expert but um
i've i've learned how to use it to a
tool as a tool to my benefit
and like i said the in-person thing is
very important
but this is the next best thing to it
it's better than email because you can't
tell someone's tone
through email right you know and i i can
look at you
i can hear your tone i can see your body
language so
i can't reach out and shake your hand
but i do have a sense of getting to know
you
and one day perhaps we'll meet in person
and and i'll feel like i do know this
guy yeah
i feel like i can get a good bear hug
out of you man yeah there you go
let's do a little rapid fire and then we
can kind of wrap up
so i'm just going to throw out a couple
words or phrases
and just tell me the first thing that
comes to your mind it doesn't
necessarily need to be
in a word or two um but just sort of
rapid fire let me know your thoughts on
this
we talked about blm what's the first
thing that comes to mind when i say blm
disorganized disorganized protests
valuable writers
um discipline
kneeling for the flag
removing confederate flags buzzes
renaming forts and bases that are named
after confederate soldiers
police shootings
better investigations defunding the
police
depending upon the department and how
it's defunded
could be it could be a positive thing
systematic racism
needs to be eradicated
the use of the n-word
needs to be eradicated what about when
black people use the n-word
needs to be eradicated so you want the
n-word out
yes um a couple people
uh christopher columbus
statues need to come down need to tell
the truth about columbus
mlk
positive very positive very positive
david duke
negative barack obama
um agent of change
donald trump agent of divide
of divisiveness joe biden
wait and see wait and see
um first person that comes to mind that
i give you the opportunity to say a name
who comes to mind
uh ebook and evil he will give me a why
he [ __ ] evil
uh he's one of my heroes one of my many
heroes evil knievel why is that
because he is one man you know
they say you cannot cheat death uh you
know
death takes you on his own terms evil
and evil cheated death
many times evil knievel died on his own
terms
he should have been dead a thousand
times over all the crazy stunts that he
did
but death could never take him he died
of natural causes
even though he broke every bone in his
body he should have died
you know crashing on his motorcycle way
up in the air jumping over cars and
trucks
and canyons and stuff um he didn't die
he died when he wanted to die of natural
causes he lived under his life evil
community that he's my hero
other than chuck berry favorite musician
elvis presley pie top perkins johnny
johnson
little richard jerry lee lewis
hip-hop in america today
fine when it spreads positive messages
favorite hip-hop artist
zero you know not that
not that i dislike it it's not something
that i that i follow with great deals
you don't listen to everything
well i listen to it but i don't really
have a favorite artist's work who comes
to mind when i say hip-hop
um what's your name lauren um
lauren hill respect fuji's
you know that song okay um more likely
to get along blacks and whites
or democrats and republicans whoever's
what needs to be done to make democrats
and republicans
come together if you could you sit down
and you
bridge the gap between the kkk and a
black person
and black american what needs to be done
with
republicans and democrats these days
tell the truth
on both sides stop politicizing and
and don't you know don't be afraid to
break loyalty
when something is wrong in your own
party your most racist experience in the
last
decade every time i'll be the plant
member
every time yeah sure why else are they
in the planet they're racist
there's nothing that comes to mind like
that was damn
ridiculously racist i mean you know
i've had you know just fights and things
like that you've had fistfights
oh plenty of times yeah with clan
members i know
you versus one clan member or you versus
multiple clan members
both both wow i put people in the
hospital i put people in jail
wow now fortunately you know those
instances are few and far between
but i beat them on the street and i beat
them in court
um how often have you feared for your
life
many times but not as many as as i
probably should have
wow there's that evil knievel quality
within you
[Laughter]
interesting if you believe you know if
you believe in something
you're going to put yourself out there
the difference between
ignorance and stupidity
um knowledge that changes you
and having knowledge that you refuse to
use
what frustrates you most
lack of exposure how do you mean by that
people are not willing to expose
themselves to things
with which they are unfamiliar that goes
back to the traveling
um what we talked about what shocks you
the most that people who see the light
um don't believe in it some people
some people don't believe that water is
wet unless you drown them in it and even
then
they have their doubts
[Laughter]
how deep that's stupidity how deep yeah
wow how do you use that water
how deep is daryl
it depends on who you ask is daryl
a romantic oh absolutely
okay i don't think so you're like yeah
baby white in the house ladies and
gentlemen
um is there anything that offends you
yes racism offends me which is why i've
i've you know
divided my my music career listen i
would much be
rather be on the stage playing rock and
roll and seeing people out there dancing
and shaking due to my sounds
my music rather than be at some clan
rally watching them
you know light across on fire and
proclaim white supremacy
got it but but uh you know i i'm
offended that this is happening in my
country
where there was a time when we could
travel
and we americans could travel anywhere
in the world
anywhere in the world and we were
revered
and today we are the laughingstock of
the world why do you think that is
uh for for our behavior and for our
current leadership a couple more and
then what we can wrap up mr davis um if
you could go back in history
and change something or someone
what would that be if i could change
something
i would try to incorporate
more of people's history being taught
in schools uh all americans history
being taught in schools
and not just relegated to one month
but put it under the uh general
curriculum of american history
not american history and black history
gotcha black history is american history
is what you're saying
just like you say confederate history is
part of american history yeah
and when you finish the rapid fire i
want to say something about about the
veteran history
say it right now okay um you know you
mentioned uh
walton two things uh the n word and um
and and you know what i think about
taking down confederate monuments and
flags
okay the n word uh is offensive
okay and he said you know
is the defensive when black people use
it yes it should be eradicated there too
now i often hear the question well how
come um
you know you all get offended white
people use it but would you use it
against you you
get your own time too well here's the
difference
i'm not justifying its use nobody should
insult anybody
um but but here is the difference uh
if if you and your brother
are having an argument and you know like
the siblings do
and um and your brother calls you an sob
it's a moot point because if you're an
sob what is he
you got the same you got the same mother
so it's
it's another boy so if somebody calls me
if somebody black calls me the n word
what is he
it's you know the old cliche the pop
calling the kettle black
gotcha it's a moot point but if i'm not
your brother and i call you an sob i've
just insulted your mother
and you're gonna knock my teeth out so
if somebody who who's not black is
calling me an sob
i mean uh that's a lot more offensive
than somebody who looks like me makes
sense so it shouldn't it shouldn't be
done at all
now i'll tell you you know the um uh he
passed away
um a few years ago a couple years ago
the activist comedian dick gregory
of course tech gregory yeah great beard
very funny man
for serious man you knew probably knew
him before he had the graveyard exactly
yeah
he's a friend of mine he was and he just
passed away
but he and i uh participated in a lot of
protests together
um he told me a story one time that
you'll appreciate
the the rolling stones were coming to my
hometown chicago
and uh of course you know they don't
have to advertise in advance
they can advertise the night before the
concert and the whole people are going
to show up to see the rolling stones
exactly right and so back then it's like
in the 80s or something
um back then you know you couldn't get
tickets online there was no online
you had to go to ticketron or
ticketmaster and
and people would camp out the night
before make a big line all the way
around the block
to get in that door to help company to
go to ticket to catron and get their
tickets
and at the mall or whatever and so there
had been an announcement you know that
the stones were coming and so people you
know took off working went out there and
you know camped out on the sidewalk
spent the night out there and you know
to wait to the next one to be the first
to get that door and get front row
tickets or whatever
and so big long line i mean morning came
it's almost time for the for the mall to
open
and this black guy pulls up in this car
along the street to the sidewalk a big
long line
he pulls up right by the front door he
gets out and he walks through the front
of the line
and these guys have been there all night
oh no no no no no lion's back there
buddy
and you know just move him back and he
comes
forward again and this time they called
him the n-word
and picked him up and carried him
over to to the tarp to the to the street
that goes around the mall by the side at
the end of the sidewalk and said
you stupid n word the line is back there
and threw him out on the street
he got up brushed himself off got inside
his car
started his car back up then he got out
of the car
and he said to them you know you can
call me stupid
and you can call me the n word but i'm
the stupid n word
that has the keys to let you all in
there
[Laughter]
so with that he got back inside his car
and drove to the end of the line on the
other side of the mall
and opened that door first so all the
people that at the end of the line got
to go get their tickets
wow yeah what's the message with that
you better watch you call the n word
maybe maybe you shouldn't use it at all
right great so you know um you know
without even seeing why he was uh you
know that they
they perceived him to be jumping the
line yeah not realizing
he's a maintenance guy he's
he could have opened any door in the
mall and because you spent the night
there the longest
he's going to open your door first but
you jump to the conclusion
without realizing and you all called him
an n word and threw him out in the
street
okay so anyway uh so yeah that word
should not be used by anybody
and and and i i i tried black people for
you to use
if you're not gonna insult somebody else
outside of your race why do you wanna
insult somebody in your race
i listen to a lot of hip-hop you know i
listen to a lot of music
obviously we've talked about you know
jackie wilson being my favorite artist
we talk about all different sorts of
music but you hear
the you know using the n-word which you
know nobody
should use but they say well it's not
the with the hard
r but with an a at the end you've heard
this
yeah i heard all that is it what are
your thoughts on like did you hear it in
all the rap songs it's with an
a at the end not an er yeah but listen
why why don't i just say hey hey you
inward
and instead of saying you know with er
at the end
why would you say n word the same
meaning
i mean you say meaning okay so if i said
you know this is a crock of bull spit
i think you know what you mean exactly
exactly so what's the point
it has the same implication the word
needs to go
the way together okay so the confederate
uh monuments and flags let's talk about
that
for a second yes here's the thing we
went to war
against well let's put it this way most
most white americans in this country
are of british descent they were the
first ones to to come to these shores
right the keratos pilgrims the puritans
pilgrims
all that captain john smith and all
those people all right
and and he had an affair with pocahontas
he liked some dark meat
hey you got it so um
uh leg man instead of press man right
so the majority of of white americans
are of british descent
um we went to war against
against great britain and many americans
have
ancestry that fought in that
revolutionary war
right and we beat
great britain which is why two months
ago
we celebrated in this country called the
fourth of july
independence day right now do
these americans who have british
ancestry
who fought against us do they honor
great britain by building statues out
here of king george the third
and flying the union jack no the winner
does not get to build his statures or
flat his flags
on the winner's land on december 7th
we were bombed in pearl harbor by the
japanese
we went to war against japan there are
plenty
of japanese americans in this country
that are as american as anybody else
and we beat japan
they have ancestors who fought against
us do they
and of course they honor their ancestors
they may not approve of the war but they
don't get out here
and build statues to emperor hirohito
and fly the japanese flag
we went to war against germany
there are tons of german americans or
americans of german descent
in this country and you know they had
ancestry
that fought in the third reich they had
to
because their leader was a dictator you
either honored him
or you were exterminated unless you
escaped to poland or somewhere
all right so do these german americans
um build statues of joseph gerbils or
adolf hitler out here
and fly swastikas no not unless they're
neo-nazis or something
all right we beat germany the winner the
loser does not get to fly his flag or
build his statues on the winner's
property
guess what the confederacy lost the war
they need to get over it they don't need
to build their statues or fly their
flags this is the united states of
america
not the confederate states of america
the csa
right the confederacy lost now should
the statues be
ripped down and destroyed no they should
be taken down
and placed in a in a museum or build a
confederate memorial park
and place them there and people who want
to go and honor those statues and flags
go do so that's part of our history put
them there
but they do not represent this country
those states
that that fought against the union were
seditionists
they were they were they they tried to
they they created
civil unrest to destroy the unity of
this country we are the united states
there should only be one flag you you
speak with somebody and they'll say
well the civil war wasn't about slavery
it was about states rights
okay yeah the state's right to own a
slave
that's what states rights means right
you know it's our right to do what we
want to do we want to own slaves with
our own slaves
states rights to own slaves so it's like
two parts to that
the slavery is a part of it so it's uh
it's the state it's lately what the
business part of it right because
the people in the listen you've heard
the term you know she comes from old
money
he comes from old money right we know
what old money is right
old money is the money that came off
plantations way back then
people picking cotton bitten tobacco
stuff
that stuff the white people weren't
working
they weren't paying those slaves they
were making all the money
from free labor that's why the civil war
was fought
to free the slaves so now if you if
you're going to free these people how
are you going to make money
you were making money for free you've
heard the term
money doesn't grow on trees yeah
in those days money did grow on trees
because you didn't have to work for it
you had slaves doing your work for you
and you weren't paying them
and all you were doing was just getting
money so you had a money tree and you
were in it
you would say today in your backyard but
back in those days so you had a money
tree on my plantation
you know and when and when somebody
would say uh you might be too young to
remember this expression
or something like it's none of your
cotton picking business of course i
remember that yeah
yeah where did that come from clearly
another cotton picking business right
right yeah what was the cotton picking
business
right the slaves you know so it's a
derogatory story
um you know he comes from the wrong side
of the tracks well that's the black side
of the tracks in the south because the
railroad tracks divided the white side
of town to the black side of town
so the wrong side of the traps were the
black side of the tracks gotcha you know
um so yes you know so these people
were fighting because their income was
going to be impacted if slavery were to
end
they made tons of money off of cotton
all your clothes were made out of cotton
back then
they didn't have polyester you know and
of course tobacco was a big thing still
is a big thing
you know i mean how long has it been
since uh you couldn't smoke in public
places
you're just a few years right yeah maybe
10 years of things you know maybe 15
years ago or whatever
um but up up until then tobacco was a
big amazing man tons of money
that is old money old money comes from
plantations new money comes from silicon
valley
all right so the war was fought over
slavery
and and in in history books uh in the
north they teach
you know it was about slavery in the
south but none other knows about states
rights
you know yeah the state's released waves
there's a part b to that
yeah respect that was that was really
the
the rapid fire thank you for kind of
digging deeper on those two topics
can we say one more thing you know
people say no
it's not you know that flag is not about
you know it's about heritage
well first of all the confederate flag
is not what most people think it is
the confederate flag is a different flag
from the one that you see with the cross
and the stars and and things uh that was
the battle flag of the confederacy
that's the fact they went to war with to
defend slavery
that they are that they are misnaming
the confederate flag the fairfax is a
little bit different
um that battle flag is what people call
the confederate flag
that that was the flag that fought
for slavery and the state's rights to
own
slaves um but and when you say you know
no no it's not about hate it's about
heritage
listen the south has a lot to be proud
of
a whole lot to be proud of a lot of good
things came out of the south
slavery was not one of them all right
and if you think that flag
represents your heritage all you have to
do is go on google
if you don't want to go to one
physically go on google just google clan
rally kkk rally and click on images
you see all these images people in rows
and hoods holding confederate flags
now you call that a hatred you say oh
i'm not associated with that though
hate people i don't hate people well if
that's a hate group when they're flying
your flag your heritage flag they're
flying because it represents hate
and in berlin uh with berlin and munich
and
others in germany today the swastika is
banned
you cannot fly the swastika in germany
you can't even fly it
privately privately can't even do it you
will go to jail
so guess what the uh the neo-nazis over
there use in place of the swastika
they use our confederate flag get out of
here that's what they use there
yeah you see neo-nazis in germany
walking down the street with confederate
flags
because to them is the symbol of white
supremacy just like it is here too
all right but people say no no no it's
about heritage all right so my thing is
this
go to a clan rally with me and if you
see somebody
flying a confederate flag i want you to
go to that person in the roman hood
with the confederate flag and tell them
that's not what it stands for
give me back my flag whether they give
it back to you or not
if you do that i will come to your house
and i will take your confederate flag
and i will hoist it up your flat bowl
for you i have yet to have any takers
nobody's doing that while we're on that
topic if you took me to a clan rally
right what would happen
um you'd probably be called a race
trader because uh
you're there with me and and you're not
standing uh with them
for them now if they now if they find
out that i'm jewish
now what uh you are you are the biggest
problem
you you're in a bigger problem than
black people jewish people are a bigger
problem than black people according to
the kkk
that changed uh it started to change in
the late 50s
and and it began changing uh throughout
the 60s
because uh what they consider
uh the biggest problem is are the jews
they call it zog z-o-g
which stands for zionist occupied
government
zol and they came to the conclusion
that and this this is um the whites of
all white supremacists
neo-nazis clan whatever that the jews
are are running the media uh they own
all the tv stations all the newspapers
they they own the banking system and all
these things
and it's jealousy because they were too
dumb
to to do it themselves or whatever and
jewish people figured out how to
how to create a a valuable and a viable
banking system uh surely they they do
they do run a lot of media etc that's
what they do
you know but because these people didn't
have
the the brain cells to do it themselves
or whatever they're envious they're
jealous
and so those people who run the media uh
black people are now the pawns of the
jews
that's what they think in their mind the
jews run everything and we are the pawns
is that the drug lord and the dealers on
the streets
so if i if i came and and met with
a kkk member like with you you're saying
if the two of us sat down
daryl and adam we're gonna go meet some
kkk members you would say that they
would hate me more than they hate you
yeah because because your people control
my people don't feel
we're not we're not smart our brains are
small
you know but you figured out ways to
connive and do all kinds of things to
get in control
because jews are a race they're not a
religion they're a race
according to these people all right so
so your race
is in a position that they are not in
they should be the ones controlling the
media
the radio the tv stations the movie the
movies
uh the media and and the banks
you know but the jews you know that you
know that race has somehow slipped by
hitler was right and when you see them
marching down the street
they're talking about uh in their
megaphones six million was not enough
that's why that's why they have
holocaust deniers
it's it's that jealousy thing
is that as they put it so they must have
really
really hated sammy davis jr a black jew
oh yeah yeah well
well maybe one of these days i'd go with
you to a clan rally okay
and uh i'll shave i'll put on a
different hat it won't look as as jewie
we'll see where it goes man this has
been this has been incredible
um what are your long-term goals i mean
you're in the thick of things right now
where do you see you're 62 i want to say
right you're going to be with us for a
handful of more decades right
let's hope so um what are your long-term
goals where would you like to see
everything that you've done where would
you like it to lead to
i'd like you to lead to more people
taking
my my template and improving upon it
i know it could be improved um because
you know i'm not the
uh begin all end all uh there's always
room for improvement
and i've done and i'm doing you know
what i'm what i believe i'm capable of
doing
but i know there are people out there
who can take it and and build upon it
and improve it
and i hope it will inspire more people
to do so
and take it to even greater heights what
would you want your legacy
to be
let's see rock and roll race
reconciliation
rock and roll race
reconciliator yeah i like the ring of
that
i like r r r r r
d d d and the r rr i dig
it overall what do you want to be known
for we talked about your legacy the rock
and roll race
uh reconciliator what do you like when
people think of daryl davis
you know 100 years from now they googled
daryl davis oh he was that guy
that dot dot you know i mean
i i'd rather be known you know musically
i mean that's that's what makes people
happy and that's why i got into music to
make people happy
so at the end of the day you consider
yourself a musician who changes
absolutely
absolutely you know listen let me tell
you
how i view it as a musician okay
i spent a lot of time uh playing with in
other people's bands
being their musical director or being a
side man like you know when i when i
play with chuck
uh for example barry um if if um
sometimes i was in a position as musical
director i would have to rehearse
whatever band he had and direct them
you know how to follow him etc uh other
times
um you know i i'm just a side man
you know and somebody's been you know
they're the front person i'm just
playing backup piano for them
back at guitar or whatever uh but as a
bandleader in my own band i'm the front
man i'm the leader
and my job as a band leader is to bring
harmony
between the voices on my stage whether
they are the instrumental voices
the piano bass drums guitar saxophone
whatever else i have in the band
and and the human voices the singers
right we want harmony
the only time that i want dissonance
is when i interjected into the music
intentionally
and that can be done for effect like i
want to create a certain mood so i
i put some some strange thing in there
to joke the audience
you know that's called a dissonance
because it doesn't belong within the
harmony of the music
uh if dissonance happens randomly
and and not intentionally the best noise
somebody hit a bad note or somebody sang
out of human somebody made a mistake you
know
what they were playing with that's where
james brown will knock you five bucks
right there
that's right and james brown will make
you rehearse until four o'clock in the
morning
even if one person made a mistake the
whole band has to come and reverse
until four o'clock in the morning yeah
exactly he turned around go like this
five bucks or whatever yeah that was a
dissonance
so the only time you want dissonance is
is when a
as a band leader is when you
intentionally inject it for effect
all right so so i spend my time on stage
trying to bring harmony between all my
various voices
instrumental and vocal isn't it natural
when i step off the stage
i'm done and i'm out in society don't i
want harmony there too
of course i'm a band leader my job is to
bring harmony whether it's on stage or
off stage harmony
yeah um you're bringing harmony you're
you're you're causing these kkk members
to completely change their lives right
you're the spark plug
that makes them say what am i doing with
my life uh
that must change you how have you
changed
in this process well i've changed in
realizing
that people can change because when i
first went into this
the you know the change thing was was
not in my mind at all
uh you know i had no reason to believe
that these people are going to change
all i wanted was to find out
how you hate me when you don't even know
me that's all i want to know
write a book about it i want to write a
book about why you people think this way
um because as kids you've heard it i've
heard it
everybody's heard it a tiger does not
change his stripes
a leopard does not change his spots so
why would i believe
that a klansman would change his robin
hood
right so i'm i'm not going in with the
idea
you know you need to give this up give
me your robe no i just want to know why
you're making us all
you know and then we're going to shake
hands we're going to walk away and
you're going to continue
dating i want to continue doing what i
do but
um what happened was people began
changing
and i thought wait a minute i'm onto
something here i thought a tiger didn't
change his stripes and i never didn't
change his spots
but now i've changed clinton is changing
his robin hood
and it happened again and again and
again so that's why i keep doing it
but i had made a mistake my mistake was
in believing that because the leopard
did not change his spots on the clansmen
i mean
a tiger not changed his stripes that a
clansmen will not change his roman hood
that's a mistake because what we have to
understand
is this a leopard and a tiger
are born with their uh spots and stripes
a klansman is not born with racism
that's a learned behavior
so what can be what can be learned can
be unlearned
so that is true a tiger cannot change
your source stripes
a leper can not change your stripes or
vice versa
because they are born with those uh with
those things
racism you're not born with is learned
but a klansman can change his robe
yes indeed wow so um
last thing um
are you optimistic about the future of
race relations
in the united states i don't get
involved in anything that i can't do
so yes absolutely absolutely and we are
in the best time of our lives
right now okay there's always gonna you
know anytime you have change
there's gonna be upheaval because people
are creatures of change
i mean people people features of habit
and change disrupts them
all right so yes we're in the best time
in
in the 20 since the 20th century right
now
uh and i say that because we're turning
our page
and we turned the page with rosa parks
we turned the page for dr king
throughout the 60s we turned the page
when barack obama went into the white
house
uh today we're turning a page with these
protests
um and and we're seeing more
you know you think we're seeing a lot of
division out there
yes there is a lot of division out there
uh that's because of the upheaval people
don't like to change
but what are we seeing different today
than we've ever seen before we we've
always had protests
out in the streets saying no justice no
peace we want equality
enough's enough we've heard those
slogans for years
decades back to the 60s and 50s
all right but what are we seeing
different today
let me explain something to you we're
seeing the collect
we're seeing the results of the
collective
voice all right black people
white people have always been involved
in our protests
even back to the fifties with rosa parks
there were there was a smattering of
white people
who who saw you know this is right i
need to do i need to
do to support this um in the freedom
rides
uh in the 60s trying to integrate the
bus stations in the south
white people took part in that white
people were beat just like black people
by the clan at the birmingham uh bus
station
because they were considered race
traders they were supporting these black
people
you know they they wanted one waiting
room not a black waiting room and a
white waiting room
all that kind of stuff when they're in
segregation um
so we've always had some white people
who participated with us
black people did not put barack obama
in the white house it was white people
who put him in the white house
because black people only make 12 of the
of the us population
and and not all 12 of us are eligible to
vote
either because we're not registered or
we're under age
or we're felons or whatever case may be
that you know that you're not
qualified to vote all right even if
all 12 percent of black people in this
country including
newborn babies were able to vote that
still would not be enough
we still needed a great portion of white
people to join
us to get that man in the white house
right 20 years ago
barack obama or any other black person
could not have won the white house
because the attitude was not there for
enough white people to to consider
uh voting for a black man by 2008
there were enough white people where the
attitude had changed
where they would say you know i like
that guy's policies yeah he's got my
vote
checked right so it took
that number of white people to join in
with us
to get him in the white house we could
not have done by ourselves that
collective force
all right you look at the protests
starting in the 60s or 50s wherever
okay we always saw a smattering of white
people with us
today look at the protest you see a
mass of white people and as a result
changes are happening a lot faster all
right in the past
the the establishment that's that's a
polite word of saying
the white power structure all right uh
they look and they see the protest is
something about a sea of black people
with a few sprinkles of salt amongst the
pepper
right there like this they didn't want
to hear what we had to say they just
shut us down they didn't appear we can
march all day
all year long they don't care all right
now
when the you know back then if
if a police officer were to be charged
let alone fired in those rare instances
it took
months months of investigation to set
the other
and then maybe the guy would get fired
and convicted
today is happening boom boom like that
within a week the cops charged he's
fired by baboon
what's the difference look at the
protesters
the power structure the establishment is
seeing more and more people
who look like them so now they're
pulling out the earplugs
or they're putting in their hearing aids
and they're listening
they're listening they're like oh damn
you know maybe we better
reconsider this you know and so now
change is happening
and while these protests in the wake of
george floyd
and people are now understanding listen
george floyd was not was not an anomaly
we've had thousands of jewish fluids of
course this
yeah this jewish floyd is a straw that
broke the channels back
and coronavirus of course helped with
that um
because people are not at work they're
at home they're watching tv
they're seeing this unfold before them
and they have time to
do some introspection and reflect on
whoa well
this is wrong now i get it now i
understand what you know what uh
what they've been talking about all
these years about police brutality and
blah blah blah
i need to get out there in the street
and protest you know
and despite the coronavirus being out
there
these people are so committed to getting
out there and protesting
to do what's right all right so we see
this big sea of white people
that again there's that collective voice
that gets things done
and while the protests were geared
predominantly towards
police misbehavior and police racial
profiling and all that stuff
there has been a larger ripple effect
than we've ever seen
in this country the ripple effect being
nascar banning the confederate flag
legislation to take down
those statues the state of mississippi
of all places taking the confederate
flag
out of their flag whoever heard of such
mississippi
you're doing it you know i remember
seeing the movie
mississippi burning yeah wow yeah
and and um and jemima and uncle ben's
food products changing the labels all
kinds of things are happening
you know more conversations about this
that's that ripple effect
what caused that ripple effect that
collective voice
so that's the key people coming together
and working together is what creates
change
a lot quicker than people working by
themselves and see
that's what i was trying to stress to
those people in that movie
accidental courtesy we need to work
together
you do what you got to do for systemic
racism i do what i have to do for
individuals
let's let's cooperate and coordinate you
know
together we can beat this problem but
how we're going to beat it
fighting each other stupid that's what
they weren't getting
and now we see how it works work
together on the common problem
you know and uh so that's what you know
that's what we need to focus on
the collective voice like i said
talking at somebody talking about
somebody
and talking past somebody doesn't work
talking with somebody
is the key working together
respect and a willingness to listen and
as you say i'm going to use your quote
when two enemies are talking they're not
fighting
it's when talking ceases the ground
becomes fertile
for violence so keep the conversation
going daryl davis
uh any final thoughts that you would
love people to understand or is there
anything that i have not asked you
that you would want people to know about
you yeah we'll consider this part one
eventually we're gonna do part two hell
yeah i love it
daryl davis thank you for being a part
of valuetainment hey thank you for
having me i really really appreciate it
you know and
it's people like you know like you who
are not afraid to uh
to talk about these uh these tough
topics and things like that
who are willing to put yourself on the
line and take criticism for
giving people like me a voice things
like that uh
you know you are an agent of change and
these are the things you know that we
need more people willing to have these
conversations
because these conversations should have
been had decades ago
had they been had decades ago we
wouldn't be in this situation right now
but we've been we've been sweeping it
under the carpet locking in the closet
and it's become a pressure cooker and so
you know if you don't release that valve
you know what happens
it explodes and we saw that explosion in
charlottesville we're seeing it right
now
on the streets of portland and wherever
else so
it's it's the uh the people like you are
our pressure cooker valves you know that
that release the steam
and uh and i really appreciate all the
work that you do well it's an honor
even sitting down with you uh everyone
needs to see the movie
um accidental courtesy
is that where you want people to where
do you want me to send people to where
would you like people to see
is there a book that you want yeah they
can go on amazon
or itunes and get the accidental
courtesy uh
also i have my new book coming out my my
first book clandestine relationships
is that a print but the new book will
have all the information from the old
book
and uh and new stuff as well it will be
called the clan whisperer
and whisper yeah it's it's in the
editing process right now so it should
be out in 2021
okay everybody will read it it is 36
years of my um
my encounters and uh and my odyssey into
the world of the tuplex clan and
neo-nazis and other white supremacists
well let's do a round two when that book
is ready to be launched
and we'll have this conversation again
absolutely thank you so much
the rock and roll race reconciliator
yeah the infamous the notorious
daryl davis triple d thank you thank you
for being a part of valuetainment
appreciate it bye-bye what a powerful
interview i just had with daryl davis
you'd be hard-pressed to find a more
unique
story than his one thing that comes to
mind in our interview i asked him
in america today who is more likely to
get along
blacks and whites or democrats and
republicans he said without a doubt
blacks and whites which was a
encouraging to hear
but b pretty sad to hear how politically
divided we are in america today
one thing i would implore you to do is
use his two
ingredients for success with other
people
respect and listening to others respect
and a willingness to listen with that
being said i would love to get your
thoughts below please comment below
and if you have not seen pat's interview
with thomas jefferson descendant
lucian trescott check that out right
here and if you have not subscribed to
the channel
please do so below thank you for
watching and we will see you
next time
[Music]